[Music]
my name is Julie I'm gonna retain hop-on
Chinatown
so hop eyes like the one of the most
popular cuisine in Chinese culture
you put a simmering soup in the middle
of the table and then you can choose
different flavor broth the one we serve
at the tapa is a spicy beef tallow broth
you cook it with beef fat and a lot of
the Chinese ingredients and spices like
chili pepper corn Tara nice dry chili
kochi took it really has that complex
flavor that is unique in Egyptian hot
ones this is actually our signature 10
pot inside is the purple broth cooked
with chicken and the outside is the
spicy beef salad so the first thing
happy we do is pick a dipping sauce the
traditional dipping sauce you match with
a spicy broth is a sesame oil here you
see is a Citroen Avenger platter
we have swampy oh and poor blood like
people might never heard of it in a
restaurant before but if you want to
taste like authenticity and citron see
what they really eat there this will be
the pattern you order so I always
recommend people to put in the
vegetables first because it takes the
longest time to cook and so like the
vegetable won't absorb the flavor of
other ingredients after I put in the
vegetables and actually I recommend is
put in the meat and the organs I just
put in the beef tongue tip if night on
10 times - you don't see any rap parts
on the meat might be a little spicy
the next thing I'll put in is the beef
tripe this also called like beef stomach
it's one of the signature dish
and it's the trunk was in eight seconds
then this is good to eat the meat I'm
putting it now it's primary but since
the media is so fresh and premium you
can only put in for like eight or ten
seconds then you can eat it I like to
eat my meat in a clear broth so I can
get the most taste after me at last
I'll recommend putting the pork blood
the swamp hill and the chicken gizzard
it's better to eat them like after you
boil them for like two or three minutes
and they can absorb all the flavor
that's already in the soup I recommend
people put in a seafood after me so the
broth will taste like seafood the last I
will put in starch like the vermicelli
noodles any starch would actually absorb
all the flavors and thicken the soup but
everyone has their own taste so everyone
has their own way to cook hop on
I've been going to Chandru and try a
harp as soon as I was little so you know
I had the flavor in my palate and then
when I moved to New York I feel like
this is something I can open the whole
harp experience to whoever ahead hop up
it's good for going out with friends
family you guys all cooking together
there's a lot of like teaching that's
what I try to bring to New York from
Chengdu
you